we've got ourselves an in-studio guest
of note he is joining us courtesy of his
friends at pizza hunt and he is a dallas
cowboy of note to say the least the
unanimous selection of defensive rookie
of the year and definitely had a great
run for defensive player of the year
period he is micah parsons good to see
you sir how are you i got it
you can stand up for him too my head
will get cut off in my camera oh very
good i just stay right here good to see
you good to see you too
good to see you this is great last time
i saw you i was getting ready to get an
award you were definitely getting ready
to get awarded your game face was on
i'll be honest with you
and um i i you know you could see the
sound that's right here my dad uh my
desk best dad ever i've got three
children um and i got to meet your boy
malcolm right right there on the red
carpet
and you had the look of somebody who's
been cooped up with a three-year-old in
a car in traffic for about an hour and a
half
look is that what did i get that right
or what was the combination everything
was a lot of people a lot of nerves was
going you know i was real nervous it was
like you were i was nervous okay what
were you nervous about
you know there's a lot of awards that i
was up for so you know i i just didn't
know which ones i was going to win for
sure you wanted them you wanted them all
you wanted to sweep them all zone of
them all okay
all right because your your your boy
came in like we were right in front of
you my wife and i susie
and we got to meet you guys look at that
there's a photograph right there
and i think malcolm's showing my wife a
boo-boo on his finger that was going on
that sounds like him
i'll be honest there i am inspecting it
as well i didn't see anything on his
hand either you know he he's a magician
with the ladies
he obviously gets it from his dad
you know um he really knows how to work
him good i tell you
even even the girls that the girl that i
had you know
uh he kind of works his magic
and stuff like that like i don't know
he's he's
he's in bad good way in a very good way
very productive way he's i can tell
that's my son you know
like
i can't lie about it
he's just proof of proof every time i'm
around him that's my boy right there
beautiful beautiful boy he was just a
handsome kid and he seemed like uh he
was he was dominating that red carpet
and naturally too
natural he's gonna be on the big screen
one day well he
he definitely uh met at the point of
attack that's for sure that was
definitely
on the red carpet it was a big night so
what would you would you
what'd you take away from honors you had
fun i did have i thought it was really
cool from my first experience i never
watched it on tv okay or nothing like
that but from our first experience
everyone that came out all the celebs
all the players that was a really cool
event it was a lot of fun
and what did you know that you were
unanimous selection that you got 50
votes i did not know i was unanimous
that was like surprising because when
defensive player of the year came up it
was like me donald tj yeah and then
when
they came up they just kind of walked up
next to me and i'm like i probably won
you know
but when i was like unanimous i only
played my clip i was just like yeah
nobody else
yeah nobody else i didn't realize nobody
else was there
nobody well i mean you kind of separated
yourself micah that is for sure
and we spoke um on this show before you
were getting drafted and we were talking
about it
and
was the cowboys were the team you wanted
right yeah that's the one you wanted all
along correct yeah and so when you
finally got the call from jerry jones
what was that like for you oh man it was
like so surreal because i remember like
mid-season and you know like why
everyone there's like ah
like you could be a top five guy so i
was like cool cool
and you know me and my boy over there
was like um
you know
oh i like i pray i go to dallas bro like
you know how fun it'll be like go to
dallas and at that point there was that
like the fourth pick maybe like they was
like they had like a top six picks i was
like oh perfect like i could fall to
dallas i'm hearing things like i could
really go there
and then um
day in the draft when i got drafted i
was like yes bro like fine like this is
what i wanted like
i wanted to be at the start that you
wanted to go and start hitting people
right away uh when did you realize that
the nfl was something that you could
be really really good at when did that
hit you throughout i was really saying
can't like
at first it was like it was a couple
days of me just getting back into
football like you know because you
didn't play for a year right now for a
year right so i was just getting back
into it again back into it
and like i started like
you know going upward it's getting
better like finally feeling like myself
again moving something good and people
like like teammates coming up hey man
you're killing it like keep going like
you know what i'm saying so then you
know big tyra smith hall of fame guy
coming to you like hey like if you do
this you'll be so much better than lc
did it then like that did zeke did it so
they're kind of giving me pointers and
like what what pointers were they giving
you like it's like you gotta use your
speed
so i was like you know cause i never
really like pastors in college and i
didn't really like do it a lot coming in
but i knew i could do it you know
and it was like use your speed you got
threatened threatened and then you got a
counter like they just give me pointers
or like the steps just like where i
should go point of attack things like
that
and then
when
coach q anytime was pass rush he'll calm
me down do like two reps like he kind of
worked me in like he'll have me go
against the second stringers like second
and third third stringers the first day
woke them up then he had me go against
the second string
looked him up and then he's like hey
today's day i'm gonna put you against
the big dogs
and they're in completely different
groups too so i went over there to
big tyron i'm talking about i was all
nervous too because i was like i never
go against someone as good as him before
and i'm talking like he cripped me up a
little bit but i was fighting it and you
know what i'm saying i was like dang
like i didn't really do my best because
i was nervous
and now he put me against lc lc had a
little stab like you know but
those are just those pretty nerves that
i had and then like as i got used to
going against him i was just all right
it's just regular now well i have to
follow up did you work them up too
eventually i would never put that on tv
[Laughter]
that's the last second
and some days people like hey you
actually had like a real good one right
there like that was a good movie you had
hit me with i was alright cool okay
even the walkthroughs he grabbed me up
like i'm a little boy and i'll be
telling him you gotta stop that so i
don't want to deal with that i would
never put that out there
i want to make it sure we're as cordial
as possible of course these are your
teammates too you want to win
championships with these kids michael
parsons here on the rich eisen show
courtesy of pizza hut so
um okay
what what what happened in the playoffs
what happened sorry tj i had to ask that
question i just turned you off
like
i like it was the penalties like
they're like i wouldn't like i don't
like to blame it on like defining
moments because there were so many
defining moments like
third down penalties
there's
not handing the ball to the ref whatever
that is and there was like
the turnovers
the
like i don't think like we came out to
play championship football
well why why do you think that happened
i wouldn't say it was a lack of
preparation but like
in games like that like you know playoff
games like you look at this last
playoffs all the games came down to the
wire
every yard counted and i just felt like
we gave up too much free stuff free
money like
in a game like that they should have to
work for every yard
every every down
things like that were you guys tight
were you tight coming out were you what
do you think
i could say you could definitely feel
like the nerves like it was a lot of
pressure like
it was like oh now they're back what can
they do with it there was definitely a
lot of pressure i feel
but you know i still don't like to make
excuses
like you got to win that game
you know so that's tough
a tough way for your first season with a
huge huge burst onto the scene
to what do you owe micah parsons your
ability to wreck a game like where
where does that come from
what do you think i would just say the
killer mindset
so i'm big into like motivational videos
and stuff like that what do you mean
like i love like learning like i love
like grasping knowledge of like how to
train my mind to be a killer
so
i watch like lion videos i watch you
know
i watch like mike tyson videos muhammad
ali
michael jordan kobe
even military videos
like
because those are trained killers so you
you're watching videos of what lions in
the wild just mauling other animals is
that what you're saying that sort of
thing yeah but i also listen to the
words of how to like get into the
mindset
hmm
okay
and then uh and then you do that when
night before game
day before game throughout the whole
week throughout the week but um my
favorite video to listen to
right before a game i always listen to
every game is the mike tyson's uh fear
video
fear
where he's talking about putting fear in
his uh in his opponent is what you're
saying something like that like it kind
of goes like this it's like
you know as i'm
you know preparing to go out
he talks about how he's
he fears a big embarrassed like he fears
like to lose
and as like he's like
coming out like he pierces his knuckles
through his gloves like
and
as he's walking down like
he's standing and saying like the moment
that my opponent like looks down so like
like i know that he's scared of me
and i like unleash on him like he's like
telling you like all his emotions i was
like damn like
we all feel like embarrassed we all fear
like to lose like all those emotions but
when it's time you got to be a killer
so then so then i started doing that
like i started looking at like
quarterbacks in their eyes like i'll
just stare at them
and they look down so i know like
i feel like they're fearing me now like
so you stared at quarterbacks yes micah
parsons you were staring at me
like what you're doing to me right now
yeah uh-huh like i just stare but i'm
locking back and yeah you too you know
why because i have the killer instinct
of a hot television host
[Laughter]
except you know i just you know i watch
videos of other television hosts
you know i haven't you know you've
noticed i have not stopped right now eye
contact is really good
okay
now it's awkward for me i'll be very
honest with you because you keep staring
at me right now and i'm beginning okay
there we go there you go just look in my
front right there i just won a staring
contest with micah parsons live on the
richardson show i'm eating pizza oh
that's right i'm sorry okay over here so
what type of pizza you eat what are you
eating i'm eating the pepperoni and red
pepper hey very spicy is that the spicy
slices mississippi uh yeah there was was
that you that was me
so this is this is the spicy pizza
lovers pizza correct yeah um and what is
going on here in los angeles there's
there's going to be
a tattoo artist is involved in this
whole thing too there's something going
on here all right so you've got
um
pizza hut right nico hurtado who's got
oh nobody's got ink here in the studio
right nobody has got any kangaroo
tj and del tufo okay i didn't know that
so um basically what you need to do
right now is of what the first rsvp can
win the chance to have one of the the
designs applied by nico himself or one
of his artists to match the boldness of
with one of these one-of-a-kind pizzas
huh so what you got to do right now
for pizza hunt
okay so you're here with pizza hunt all
right give me a slice they got over
there are you gonna eat the spicy one no
way i'm not a spicy guy
that's why they oh they got you a cheese
what's that wrong
it's pretty soft
[Laughter]
you're just you're literally just
talking about how you've been a killer
like you're a killer tv host
you always say i want to bring one over
he's going to say i want to
gee this is not going to be good for me
yeah cheers
[Music]
[Applause]
i'm terrible at this oh god all
all
right
i just lost the steering column like you
just said best dad ever your kids are
washing
and he is shaming you now yeah
oh my god your head got real red real
fast
oh my god
no oh my god we're gonna get to the show
i just got here
my man's about to blow up over there wow
get them some water
it's not that spicy it what are you
doing i do not what are you talking
about what do you got is that no i need
something to drink chris please
liz
i'm trying to be involved in the
conversation oh my god
whoo
this is spicy what does the matter with
you what are you talking about it is not
that spicy i don't eat spicy food i do
not eat spicy food never i never eat
spicy food ever
ever
but that is wow that is something else
i just want to let y'all know
it is not that spicy rich is up here
i'm up here
we gave him a ghost pepper
did you really no oh god
[Laughter]
wow
all right now i feel better so let's
talk more about the cowboys okay no i'm
just kidding you've got a question for
him tj i know you do
dallas cowboy fan you're he's a penn
state nittany lion you know he's from
altoona like you a kid from altoona kid
from harrisburg you know just sitting
here in the rich eyes and showing el
segundo that's pretty amazing um so many
questions i guess the i'll keep it
football related position wise bro like
where do you see yourself doing the most
damage because we saw you at linebacker
obviously then they moved it to edge
russian it was just like wait a second
we've got something incredible on our
hands here so where do you feel most
comfortable where do you like it where
do you want to line up or is it
everywhere because i can see you man it
seems like your confidence level bro if
they put you in a quarterback you're
gonna get that job done they put you in
a tight end
uh receiver
where do you want to go what do you want
to do i really like everywhere
so you know i i just believe
i need to line up with the best
like i want to be best on best so if
we're at going against like like first
instance we're
the niners we were going against debo i
wanted that matchup with debo every time
wherever debo went that's where i wanted
to go
like when we were lined up against the
minnesota play linebacker wherever cook
went that's where i wanted to go like i
wanted you to be best on best you want
to travel on the best of whoever is
coming out of the backfield too is what
you're saying like running and throwing
and catching it and when we're when
we're
playing against a team like because
that's where my cover comes in place
like i cover well
yeah i noticed that yeah
and then when we're going against
uh pap mahomes the afc team we're
they're not really going to
run the ball as much as
cook maybe not they're not going to run
18 20 times a game right but they'll
pass so put me against your left tackle
your right tackle
now pass rush love it that's where you
want to go yeah because that's the best
way that i can impact the game you're
hearing how people are talking about
aaron donald now that he's won the super
bowl and everything that he could be one
of the best defensive players ever i
think he he is
like
unarguably like
i don't even think it's close
so
is that what you were you wanted to be
talked about that way one yeah
like i feel like there's only but so
many players who could do it all like
donald like donald kelown up anywhere
right on the line like there's that one
person like every 10 years i think i got
a chance to be that guy
okay
so next year what's your goal next year
what do you got
uh be the best defensive player in the
league well i mean numbers you got
numbers
no
none no you don't want to 20 sacks i
don't want to set a bar
why
because
bars are meant to be broken or like you
set a bar like you're like ah i just
reached that let's say if i set a bar
for 20 i'd get 30. right
and you're psyched to dan quinn uh
return yeah super excited what does he
bring what does he do he brings the
juice he actually brings like fighting
videos to the to the defensive meeting
groups you know every time i watch type
of hers this year
that's what he did yeah he's like
you got to put you got to knock him out
like like
he plays boxing videos first to get
hyped like right
you got the juice bud
like you he's like a
very
he just puts it away for you to want to
play for him like he don't treat you
like do this extra dose
he's never like that with you he's like
you're gonna ball out or we'll find
someone else to ball for you and you
respond to that sort of thing yeah cause
it's like
he's giving you the opportunity and the
chance so what does mike what does mike
mccarthy say to you what does the hc
city
me and coach mike don't really talk like
like he's more of an offensive coach
so you don't have you have more of a of
a relationship with quinn is what you're
saying but me and mike when coach mike
we talked he kind of like
we talk about like how i'm doing like
off the field like mentally things like
that like you know what i see out there
mm-hmm
but it's never like
you know q's like my hand-to-hand and
staying with george
and so the stuff off the field he's
talking about what like life in general
you're saying to make sure that
everything's yeah because i imagine
again did that's got to be a big jump
for you to go from
no football like college no football
than the nfl
but your head was screwed on straight
the whole pretty much all year long
doesn't change mindset never changes
i take the same mindset to everything in
life
kelly
thanks for coming on here mike parsons
really appreciate it hey you watched all
the way to the end thanks for that watch
more right here